I saw goats and llamas coming in so I
think there's a petting zoo would you
want to go in a petting zoo yeah
Mother's Day tomorrow how do you
celebrate I'm with a lot of vino Humbert
so actually so we just like to hang
around the house dress alike and you
know brunch it out and tell me about
being here today
it's just I mean we absolutely love
Maria Shriver and we love everything she
does with best buddies and just what
they're orgonite organization does for
them it's just absolutely amazing it
means a lot of time so we love
representing that yeah yeah yeah right
yeah and I think you as a mom you don't
want to ever have anyone ever singled
out so I love that they create
opportunities the one-on-one friendships
just me as a mom I think it means so
much to make everyone equal and everyone
you know have something to do right yeah
I give everyone a median home birth I
love that you're wearing a matching
outfit so my husband is like he got his
seed because he's out of town he's
wrestling in Europe right now so for my
Mother's Day gift you got this matching
outfit okay last thing how's life
life is good after cute man oh thank you
he's um he's amazing he's just he makes
me really happy which is cool and you
approve it's hard sister finally a it
took me a while as it should right thank
you but I do I approve you so sweet
birdie loves himself it's funny cuz on
our podcast that's this one say we have
Artem on as a guest which I was very
nervous about and the questions she
asked I was like I can't believe you're
asking me but she talks about some
stories of what Abby's she used to be to
him like I mean she put him through a
lot he was my opinion yeah sisters the
person you're welcome for protecting
will and for caring and be protective
you